the saw franchise is known for the 21st
century mechanical torture devices
devised by its antagonist
john kramer also known as jigsaw the
traps have become as important to a saw
movie as the gadgets are to double 07 or
i don't know like the dinosaurs to
jurassic park in fact the series has
gained a little bit of a reputation
for its masochistic tendencies so in
honor of there being a new saw movie out
i've teamed up with fellow masochists
i mean saw fan sarah hawkinson also
known as possessed by horror to talk
about our five favorite
sawtraps we also ranked the saw movies
so stick around to the end of this video
to see how everything stacks up
so for my criteria how i chose my top 5
traps is number one survivability it has
to be survivable so any fake out traps
where
they actually complete it but still die
not gonna choose from those number two
plausibility it has to seem
realistic both physics wise and human
body wise
can you really die like that can you die
that quickly from that
and finally number three originality and
creativity of course
i feel like some traps just aren't that
creative or they're used
repeatedly like the reverse bear trap or
they're just too similar to previous
traps used so i want all
original i would never have thought
about that okay starting with my fifth
favorite sawtrap of all time we have
jeff's trial
specifically the freezer room from saw
three so
this technically isn't a trap of the
woman
in the trap it is of course relying on
jeff's decision
and it is technically a test for jeff
himself and there's
a lot of traps like this where it kind
of relies on other people
or another person and these typically
aren't my favorite because they do seem
a little bit out of the person's control
so in this trap jeff must face the only
witness
that saw the hit-and-run accident that
killed his son and of course he must
decide
if he will choose to save her so the
technicality of this trap he must reach
behind
cooling pipes in order to retrieve a key
that will unlock the lock that is
holding her up and this requires him to
push his face onto the pipes ultimately
ripping flesh off
and he has a limited time to do this
because of course the
in the freezer room she is strung up
naked and water is being
blasted onto her and kind of creating
a popsicle effect so of course this is
one of my favorite sawtraps it's been
one of my favorite traps pretty much
ever since i saw
saw three however it is fifth on this
list because although technically he had
a chance to save the woman
he still needed that key to enter the
next room
the only iffy criteria that this kind of
doesn't really mean is the plausibility
we don't know how long she was hanging
there before jeff entered the room
and i don't know if she'd necessarily
become
a human popsicle that quickly maybe time
had passed i don't know we don't
know we also don't know how cold the
room is maybe it's really really cold
and she would become a popsicle
we don't know but that's the only thing
that i could fault this trap for
is a little bit of the plausibility can
you find it within you
to save another i came up with five
factors to judge the traps on
is it fair and winnable could it
effectively transform a bad person
does the punishment fit the crime does
it look cool and is it
brutal my honorable mention is gonna go
to the necktie trap from saw five i like
that there's a puzzle element the
characters have to figure out and i also
like that there's a social aspect but it
doesn't really do that well in any of my
five factors so i'm gonna have to count
that one out
so my number five is going to be the
angel trap from saw three
in this trap detective allison carey is
tested because jigsaw believes that she
spends too much time
piecing together the final moments of
the dead and that this has made her dead
on the inside
this near-death experience is supposed
to make her appreciate life again
the device is hooked into her rib cage
and the only way she can escape is by
retrieving the key from inside of a vat
of acid and she has just 60 seconds to
do so once time expires the brackets
pull her ribcage apart if she's unable
to unhook herself from the device
this is a trap that should be fair on
paper only the apprentice responsible
for setting it up
amanda rigged it by putting the wrong
key in the vat of acid because she felt
that detective carey deserved to die
kerry doesn't really deserve to be
tested in the first place she's only
targeted because she's investigating
jigsaw but if someone had lost their
appreciation for life
i could see the angel trap being a
wake-up call for them does it look cool
yes visually this is probably my
favorite trap i love the distorted view
we see of allison's face through the
acid beaker and there's just something
beautiful about the symmetry of the room
the way the colored light falls on her
and the pose that the machine puts her
in certainly lives up to the angelic
namesake
this is one of the more brutal traps in
the series based on an ancient torture
device from norse mythology called the
blood eagle
we actually see it go off on camera they
don't get fancy and try to hide it with
camera angles and editing she just gets
destroyed by this thing and it is
messy
all right in fourth place is pound of
flesh so the two
in this trap are eddie and simone who
are money lenders who
lent too much money to people who could
not pay it back and thus entered
inescapable
debt so the technicalities of this test
are whoever gives the most amount of
flesh within 60 seconds
survives and they are fighting against
the clock because during that 60 seconds
screws are being screwed into the sides
of their skull
i like this test a lot because it
doesn't say specifically how much flesh
you have to sacrifice it's just whoever
sacrifices the most
and size doesn't necessarily matter
obviously eddie is a bigger
dude and simone recognizes this and
realizes that she's gonna have to cut
off much more than just
fleshy bits in order to win so what does
she do
sacrifices entire limbs with bones
so an interesting fact about pound of
flesh is that this is actually
a reference to shakespeare's merchant of
venice this refers to a money lender who
lends money to his rival
and making the security for the
transaction a pound of flesh if it
cannot be paid back
when the rival defaults on the loan the
money lender demands the pound of flesh
and return
so another one of my biases towards this
trap and one of the reasons why it's in
my top five is because simone is played
by tenedra howard who actually won
a reality competition show for this role
she was in a show called scream queens
from lionsgate and twisted pictures a
breakout role in the next installment of
horror's biggest franchise
saw
and shawnee smith who plays amanda in
the saw franchise is actually the host
of this show so i just really like the
connection
and tenija i feel like it does such an
amazing job and was so well deserved
with this role
you want to know the best thing that
happened to me after having to cut off
my
own arm it's handicapped parking
at the damn mall number four i'm going
more recent for my next trap now when i
first saw the subway trap in spiral i
felt like it was something i'd seen
before
but after thinking about it it's
actually pretty original the subject is
detective marv boswick who was tested
because he gave false testimonies in
court to get people thrown in jail
his tongue is clamped to a metal device
overhead and he's standing on a ladder
in the middle of a subway tunnel his
objective was to get off the ladder
thus ripping out the tongue that was
responsible for all of those damaging
lies and he had until the next train
came through
to do so in this sense the punishment
really does fit the crime
we've seen a victim get tested by jigsaw
for the things they have said in the
past for example
nina in saw7 but this is surprisingly
the first time a killer has literally
gone after the victim's tongue
though i have seen it before in another
james wan property dead silence
this trap really doesn't look that cool
but it is winnable assuming it's
possible to survive something like that
and regardless of the outcome
it's very brutal
next up i wanted to rank this one higher
i'm not gonna lie just because
of what it is and how intense it is
uh the scalping seat from saw four now
this is another
layered joint test with detective rig
being tested
while the victim of the trap brenda is
also going through her own test
so the two tests are detective rig is
told not to
attempt to save the victim because that
is always in his instincts
and he is obsessed with saving everyone
around him
so this time he must fight his instincts
and allow brenda to suffer the trap i
don't want to say die because i really
don't know if scalping would really kill
you
which we'll get to plausibility in a
minute brenda who is a criminal pimp
forcing young women to prostitute for
her
is attached to a machine which is
attached to her hair
which slowly is pulling her hair off
scalping her
and as the mechanism turns a coat is
revealed on the back and rig decides to
help her before it's too late so around
the room
were evidence photos of brenda that
could incriminate her
so her test was if a cop comes to save
you you must kill him before
he can arrest you thus it is in
detective rigg's best interest not to
help the victim for the first time in
his life
so it's a little bit complicated layered
tests going on here
there's very few traps i would say in
the saw universe that have this layered
effect obviously there's joint traps
there's competitive traps there's
reliant traps there's group traps but
very few
layered joint traps so although i don't
technically believe
i mean maybe you could die from being
scalped the head does bleed a lot so
plausibility is a little iffy on this
one but i chose it as one of my
favorites and in third place
specifically because it is just one of
the most
intense traps to watch
number three for my number three i'm
taking it back once again
to saw three which contains one of the
most unique traps in the series the pig
of that
this trap features jeff denlon who can't
stop mourning for his dead son and
fantasizing about revenge on his killer
while most sawtraps attempt to transform
a victim through physical suffering the
pig vat deals in more of an emotional
suffering jeff is forced to burn his
child's old possessions in order to
obtain a key with the power to free the
judge who let the killer go off easy
if jeff is unable to do so in time the
judge will be drowned in pig guts
this is one of those rare cases where
the test subjects all survive but it
isn't without a major internal struggle
it's also effective because the goal is
for jeff to let go of his past and he
literally has to do so in order to win
so for jeff the punishment definitely
fits the crime but for the judge
not really he just made a mistake and he
nearly loses his life over it
now maybe some people will disagree but
i really love the look of this trap
particularly because we get to see the
maggot covered pigs get brought out in a
factory line and dropped into a shredder
and liquefied as they fall into the vat
i love the way the sound design makes
this even scarier and of course the
metal soundtrack adds to the intensity
when it comes to the
brutality i'm kind of split here it's
not really that brutal for jeff at all
because he's only experiencing an
emotional pain but for the judge i'd say
it's pretty rough
not only is he nearly drowned but just
imagine the smell and taste of getting
buried alive in pig gods
i take the corn silo over that any day
your soul never recovered
now you have the power to sentence his
soul
straight to hell so in second place we
have the infamous
needle pit from saw two i think this
trap is so famous and a lot of people
probably think about this trap when they
think about the saw franchise
now the test is actually for xavier but
as we know amanda is the one
who ends up in the pit so xavier picks
up amanda throws her in the pit which
just adds to the intensity it's not like
someone willingly jumped in there she is
thrown
unwillingly into the pit of needles
and of course among the needles is a key
that opens a door
where there is an antidote for the nerve
gas that is slowly being released in the
house that they're in
trapped in i should say i think this is
one of the most ultimate uncomfortable
traps to watch one of the most intense
to watch i cringe every single time even
though i've seen it a million times
of course we know if you don't reach the
antidote you could die from the nerve
gas
being pumped into the house and of
course there are many smaller traps
throughout the house that lead to the
antidote to this nerve gas
so fun fact about this trap is in order
to film it they had to remove
every single needle from every single
syringe and replace it with a fiber
needle
which took several days and they had to
use over a hundred and twenty thousand
syringes
number two the subject of our next trap
like jeff denlon is faced with more of a
psychological torture than a physical
one his name is william easton and he's
a health insurance executive for a
company called umbrella health william
was responsible for creating the
algorithm to determine who the lowest
risk individuals are if he determines
that they're unlikely to get sick he'll
offer them coverage
jigsaw sees this as william deciding who
lives and who dies and decides to give
him a taste of his own medicine in a
trap called
the gallons william is persuaded to take
hold of two chains and after a very dark
knight appearance of billy the puppet
is presented with two people on barbed
wire nuisance one is his secretary an
older woman with a history of diabetes
and a loving family
the other is his file clerk a young
healthy man with no living relatives to
mourn his laws
according to william's algorithm the
secretary should be denied coverage and
the file clerk should be treated
but when presented with a choice between
two colleagues he knows personally
the choice is not quite as easy to make
the trap takes place in a reptile
habitat it's symbolic of the
cold-blooded nature of william's
decisions
is this trap fair or winnable that's one
of my gripes with it
someone has to die here you could argue
that they're all wrongdoers for working
at a dirty insurance company but it's
not very fair to the people wearing the
nooses who are really just trying to
make a living aside from that i would
anticipate that being faced with a
traumatizing decision like this would
have caused william to reconsider his
policies at the very least
visually it's nothing special it's just
two people standing there and while it's
probably a painful way to die
it's a lot quicker than a lot of the
other traps that put a victim through
extended periods of suffering so it's
really just john kramer's creative
method of turning the tables that makes
the gallows such a memorable trap
as you can see the choice is not so
clear when you are face to face with the
people whose blood will stain your hands
all right now for my favorite favorite
sawtrap of
all time the spike trap otherwise known
as cupid's arrows from
saw four and i feel like this one is a
controversial one to put
first because there are many many more
iconic sawtraps but i just feel so drawn
to this one
and like i said in my video where we
rank all the saw movies saw four
has objectively some of the best traps
in my opinion so this trap involves
morgan and rex who are a married couple
and they wake up to realize that they
are attached by
arrows or spikes and the test is that
morgan finally has the opportunity to
break the ties
that bind her to her abusive husband so
the catches
in this is as she removes each spike or
each
arrow from her body you know pulls it
through
it will slowly make her husband bleed
out so
she is impenetrated is that a word
through
many many points of her body however
none of them lethal
whereas her husband is punctured through
major arteries i just feel like this is
such a strong scene to me because of the
emotions
attached to this couple even though we
hardly know them it's just
something that i feel so drawn to and to
watch
the intensity and the strength
and the independence i know this is way
too deep for just a saw trap but like
just go with it for a second
she's finally choosing to break ties
with her husband
is it really just her survival instinct
kicking in probably but you know she
didn't really have that going for her
when she was with her abusive husband
you know and he's pulling on the spikes
trying to prevent her from pulling it
out and it's just a very very intense
and like heartbreaking scene in a way
it's just
it's my favorite scene or favorite trap
by far
also i love the concept of this this has
to be like the most
original sawtrap in my opinion and i
just love it the human body is a
fascinating organism
this probably comes as no surprise one
of the most iconic cringe-inducing
well-balanced traps in the history of
the saw franchise comes in saw two and
it's called
the needlepit amanda is forced to
rummage through piles of syringes
causing many of them to stick into her
flesh as she relives her days as an
addict while desperately searching for
her owls
we don't know what was in the syringes
but the assumption is that it's
something pretty nasty
ultimately she finds the keem but xavier
is slightly too late when it comes to
opening the safe and the whole thing
ends up being a loss
the challenge is actually very doable
you would just need to have a lot of
willpower to keep pushing through the
pile as more and more needles pin
themselves into you but theoretically
once you get the antidote you'd be able
to survive
could the needle pit effectively
transform its subjects we don't actually
see the answer because the intended
subject never goes through the trap but
i think it's somewhat questionable
xavier probably already knew that drugs
are bad before he became a dealer and
i'm not really sure that being in their
shoes for two minutes would cause him to
reconsider his career options
at the very least it might have made a
less evil character realize how much
drugs can mess up a person's life but it
seems unlikely that it would have any
effect
this trap takes place inside of what
appears to be a nursery inside the house
when a junkie becomes addicted their
bodies become dependent on the drugs
just as a baby needs its parents to
provide for it the drug addicts need to
keep crawling back to xavier to get
their fix
i can say the punishment probably fits
the crime on this one because the amount
of needles in the pit is probably
comparable to the amount of drugs that
xavier has sold in his lifetime so
jigsaw is essentially forcing him to go
through all of it at once
does this trap look cool it definitely
looks ugly but i have to give this one
some creativity points for not just
being a big hunk of machinery like so
many other sawtraps are the yellow
lighting in this room is disgusting but
i think it accomplishes its goal to make
us feel
uncomfortable the way the needles stick
to her is really well done and i know it
makes a lot of soft fans cringe
in fact i know there are a lot of people
who can't even do a single needle so
this trap is truly a trypanophobic's
worst nightmare
where does this land on the pain scale
probably not super high
at the end of the day you're just
getting poked all over your body you're
not getting flesh ripped out of you
you're not getting burned or drowned but
i'm still gonna make a case for this
being one of the most unforgiving traps
because this is one of those jigsaw
traps that forces the participant to
harm themselves
many of the other traps are out of the
player's hands whatever happens to them
happens the thing with the needle pits
and
a few other traps in the series is that
you have to put yourself in pain to
succeed which goes against what your
brain wants you to do you can see in her
reaction how getting stabbed in dozens
of places like that
really causes the pain to stack up and
for amanda specifically it's much harder
because she has already overcome the
life of drugs
she thought it was over but now she's
finding herself being thrown back in
with no shoes at that now a lot of you
have been asking
what did i think of spyro where does it
stack up with the other saw movies
so sarah and i have created a second
video where we rank every installment in
the franchise if you enjoy my content
and the topics i talk about you'll
probably want to go ahead and subscribe
to possessed by horror i originally
found her channel and started talking to
her because i found that her reviews
tended to line up with my own horror
movie tase so she's become one of the
few critics that i actually trust
you'll find our video on the left but
before you go make sure you subscribe to
cz's world for new horrors
every week ring the death bell for all
notifications and i'll see you over in
that other video
assuming we both survive i guess if
sarah survives also i mean we already
made the video so
i think we're good